live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships it's a
toll-free number to jump in America
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five I'm Ken Coleman joined by
my colleague the the incomparable
George camel with a K this is why I love
hosting with you can you know how to
butter me up well you know you're you're
uh you're a great joy to be together the
some of the people uh out there in the
social media land where you live I stay
away from the Comets you like to uh
dance among the comments have referred
to us in our combination uh as a root
beer float that's right and we still
don't know who the root beer is and who
the vanilla ice cream is well you you
self-proclaimed that you were the root
beer and that I was the vanilla ice
cream uh I'll take it as a positive well
you're so smooth well and I got a little
zip and Zang to me zip and Zang yeah
making words up I like it George and I
here we have a lot of fun together so
we're gonna have some fun but we're here
to help you so let's go Jolie oh there I
just want you to start singing George I
want you to just bring out the guitar I
want to stay on the air I mean if you're
in Nashville and you you see the word
Jolie on the screen you know you start
thinking about dollars it's close to
generate songs it is I know but you
think Jolene and Jolie you know you see
where I was go in there I could get
there come on I could get there you
don't you didn't think Jolene
no not at all no Jolie all right she
probably hates it now Fort Worth Texas
is where she is Jolie how can we help
hi there I actually get that a lot yes
okay Ken thank you because George was
being snarky there with my Jolene
reference I know your name is Jolie but
thank you how can we help well I am used
to it so I am an 18 year old
photographer um I started my business
when I was 14. and I just graduated high
school in May
um I'm looking into being full-time but
I'm also going to be going to Community
College on a full ride here in the Fort
Worth area so I won't have any student
loan debt
um basically my question is how in the
world do I budget and set myself up for
future success when I don't have a
consistent income
great questions and I'm so proud of you
for first of all at your age doing what
you're doing going to school debt free
and wanting to be on a budget with this
I'm just so impressed with you from the
get-go what kind of money are you making
um last year my business made about
twenty thousand dollars
um that wasn't necessarily my take home
I think I took home about 13. okay
um
so but you know that was the very early
stages of everything and I couldn't do a
lot of the legal stuff until I turned 18
so there were a lot of fees that you
know I've run into trying to get
everything legal and set up what do you
expect to make this year knowing that
you're going to go into Community
College so you're going to be doing that
you think you're going to make the same
a little bit more I'm just curious what
your projections are
a little bit more I've raised my prices
a little bit and I have quite a few
weddings on the books
um so it should I'm kind of assuming
around 30. okay awesome okay so when it
comes to budgeting are you using a
certain tool right now
the budget I just downloaded the every
dollar app yes I paid for the premium
you paid for it
how about this I'll give you another
year that way when this one runs out
you'll have another year ready to get
that so hang on the line after we're
done we'll get that going but because
you have the premium version here's the
an awesome tool in there that helps with
those that have a regular income it's
called paycheck planning and so you
enter in each paycheck and it will show
you exactly when you would run out of
money based on that paycheck based on
when your bills fall
and so what you want to set up is a
prioritized spending plan so what you
would do is you list out your income for
the month you list out your expenses but
you're going to order the expenses in
the priority so obviously food utilities
housing Transportation giving those
things would come first and as long as
you have money to cover those we move on
to the next priority and the next
priority and at the very bottom of that
list is going to be life's little
luxuries maybe your subscriptions your
self-care whatever those things are for
you those come last and if you have the
money to cover them great and if you've
got a leaner month we got to make sure
we at least can cover those four walls
food utility shelter Transportation so
you know what A bad month would be for
you right
right what would that be
um I'd be about you know two to three
sessions so probably about five hundred
dollars total okay and what are your
expenses your bare bones expenses to get
by cover all the bills
um us
I would say I mean for a month I'd say
about three hundred dollars just because
I still live with my parents
um and I don't have a car note or
anything so awesome man this makes life
so much simpler doesn't it when you
don't have debt payments to think about
and giant mortgages so right now you
know life is is simple right now and the
numbers are nice and low and even with
that income you're able to cover those
bills so you're going to cover that
stuff first and that extra 200 bucks is
going to go down the list until you run
out of that money for the month
okay so it's that it's that simple and
for those of you listening out there uh
we're talking about every dollar we're
talking about this paycheck planning
feature I want to let you know that
right now we've got a really cool deal
if you go to everydollar.com George this
is a limited time I got the team to make
my own little website on there and you
will get 15 bucks off the annual
subscription and you'll get a two-week
free trial so you can check out those
features I talked about like paycheck
planning we have a new Financial roadmap
tool goal planning there's all kinds of
cool stuff our team is putting in there
and paying attention to your money is
the foundation whether you make thirty
thousand or three hundred thousand you
don't want to wonder where it's going
you want to know exactly where every
dollar is going so go check that out
everydollar.com George tell them I sent
you there you go I like this Julie he's
talking about where your money's going I
think you know where you're going what's
that long-term dream I'm curious
um my long-term goal is to just be a
full-time wedding and senior portrait
photographer
um I I actually just visited Tennessee
last week and I was in Franklin and I am
just absolutely in love with that state
um and so long term I would love to be
full-time out there oh yeah
um but really you know no matter where I
live I would just love to continue to do
this good for you well let me tell you
something George gave you the basics and
you're you're really in a good situation
being young but this business is off off
and running and you're only going to
grow it and and socking money away at
this point at this point in your journey
just save save save be more disciplined
have some fun you're 18 uh but the more
you save the more freedom you're going
to have long term and I think you're
gonna crush it you're going to be great
and if you ever get to Tennessee or move
to Tennessee this this area we're in
Williamson County George if you get out
you know some of these back roads it is
a wedding portrait or an engagement
waiting to happen and I would let Jolie
take senior portraits of you and I can
what do you think oh oh I see I never
had a good one you know I'm willing uh
I'm I'm on a couple days this week I'm
willing to bring my senior picture the
next time I'm on with George but I'll
tell you why it'll give him unlimited
fodder you should see it uh 1992 the
year was George I'm gonna have a whole
stand-up special dedicated to yourself
you see it because I don't mind it was
it was a pretty good picture for back
then back then the operating phrase hey
George and I well we got to pay some
bills with these commercials but we're
not leaving don't move
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
by their one
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
helping you win in your life in your
money in your work and in your
relationships this is the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman joined by George
Campbell we have people that are tuning
in every day to an episode of the Ramsey
Show and you're starting to learn the
language or you know what we talk about
when it comes to money and and working
relationships but you're feeling
stressed because you're stuck
financially and there's a difference
George you know this between knowing
what to do with your money and actually
doing it as Davis said for decades
personal finance is 80 behavior only 20
head knowledge and that's why we believe
in our Financial Peace University
classes this class is different and that
it is of the difference between trying
to get in shape on your own
which never works for me and uh hiring a
personal trainer you have a coordinator
holding you accountable and other people
in the class pushing you and cheering
you on and that's why this class has
worked for millions of people after nine
weeks you'll never handle money the same
way again don't just listen to the show
dive in commit to doing what it takes to
win join an FPU class at Ramsay
Solutions
.com FPU that's
ramsaysolutions.com
FPU I've got a class uh tonight in fact
I just met a nice lady that's uh in in
the class that I'm coordinating so it's
a virtual class you got to see her in
person that's exactly you're right
pretty wild see her here and then
tonight she better be there she'll see
me on the zoom right so that's pretty
wild your class is going well yeah we're
cooking with gas we got a lot of credit
cards cut up we're a little earlier in
the journey but it's been an awesome
time I mean the fact that people are
committing they're showing up week after
week following the steps watching the
lessons it's very encouraging love it
hey if you're new to the show
personality that focuses on work all
things related to work as Davis said for
decades your income is your greatest
wealth building too I want to help you
make more money and a part of that
George is doing work that you really
really love our largest study of the
large study of net worth millionaires
said that 96 of those millionaires
enjoyed their work and that's what I
specialize in so I'm throwing that out
there if you're feeling stuck or you're
feeling confused wanting to get a
promotion want to make a pivot we'll
take some of those calls today because
those play in big time to your money so
I just want to throw that out there and
George I love taking those calls with
him so we'll take your work calls your
money calls let's go Athens Georgia the
home of the University of Georgia
two-time National Championship uh
winners in college football George
that's a sport where people wear helmets
and pads
I've seen that one it has a face mask on
it there you go Casey is joining us in
Athens Casey how can we help
hey thank you all for taking my call how
are y'all good how are you I'm doing
well thank you how can we help um I just
have some general questions about how
I'm saving currently
um I am 31 I make about 3 600 a month
I have no debt
I currently have 14 000 in emergency
fund at my local bank
I have 6300 in a high yield savings
account that's for things such as like
my future house car insurance and
Christmas
um I have about a hundred thousand my
retirement accounts
and I'm trying to figure out what's the
next step I really need to be saving for
college for my son who's two
but I don't really have anything started
for that and I don't really know where
to put it I don't know if you know what
if he chose not to go to college I don't
know if I want to put it in like
you know mutual funds you know to
something that I start myself that I can
pull out or um
what I need to do from there but also I
have my husband I had started him a his
own mutual fund it's just an S P 500
um and I think it has about 3 000 in it
but it has a rule on it like we said it
where he can't touch it until he's 21
and I didn't know if that was best or
not so kind of trying to figure out
which direction to go in right now yeah
you guys have a lot going on and you
have a goal of buying a house are you
guys renting right now
yes and you said 3600 is your take-home
pay does that household or is that just
you that is just me okay what about your
husband is he working
yes he works and it's um he kind of has
variables so like it might be
I would say at minimum it's an extra 3
000 on top of mine okay I mean you guys
have combined finances right yes okay it
sounded like it was my money his money
but I wasn't sure there no I'm sorry I
said it separately because of my like my
retirement obviously a separate yeah but
okay so you guys are at baby step four
five six which means you should be
investing 15 into retirement you want to
put a little bit away for college and
then whatever is left obviously you
don't have the house yet and so that's a
goal for you guys once you get the house
we'll start paying on that mortgage and
get that knocked out and so are you
investing 15 of the household income
right now
yes
um currently the way mine is set up
specifically I don't have his exact
numbers but mine is uh nine percent at
my Roth 401k at work and they do a six
percent match and then I have a uh Roth
outside of here that's mine that I do
about 500 a month okay and that would
add up to about 15 of your income if you
do the math on that cool okay so beyond
that you also have this goal to save for
this house how urgent is the house
purchase
not urgent we have like a Five-Year Plan
maybe okay so I would set that goal for
that house purchase let's say the down
payment you want I don't know a hundred
thousand dollars I don't know what that
number is for you guys so five years 100
Grand that's 20 grand a year and let's
set up a separate high-yield savings
account so Christmas and insurance
doesn't get all mixed up with house down
payment you have a very clear uh Target
there and as you set that Five-Year Plan
I would open a state-specific 529 plan
it doesn't have to be George's you can
search around you can get with one of
our smartvester Pros on our website they
can help you find the best one for you
but a 529 plan is tax advantage for all
of those future schooling needs and the
question you said and this is a good one
again people always go I just don't know
if Junior's gonna go to college so I
don't think we should save because what
if they don't but what if they do and
what if you don't have the money and
what if their burdened with a hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and that is my bigger fear and so the
great thing about a 529 plan is that
there's some new
legislation with the secure 2.0 act that
allow you to enroll a portion of that
over to a Roth IRA if they don't end up
using it and let's also remember that
George it's not just limited to a
four-year degree so for instance there
are Tech boot camps there are all types
of certifications two-year programs uh I
was just touring a two-year program in
the film industry with our teenager
yesterday so uh all of that Casey that
529 can be used for all that this does
not have to be a traditional College
because I'll be honest with you your
little one at two years of age we're
seeing college enrollment drop
precipitously I think it's going to
continue to do so by the time that uh
he's he's making a decision I think
higher ed is going to look very very
different but you'll still have options
there it's not like you're going to
invest it and then be stuck not know
what to do with it as George mentioned
okay that sounds good yeah but you're
doing great good Mama there absolutely I
love that I like keeping it separate the
529 plan for college let's get the
retirement going in the 401K and then
for the house savings and the short-term
goals let's say less than five years a
high yield savings account is a great
place to park that money uh you know
right now the interest rates are great
it may not be back when I was saving for
a house the interest rates were about
two percent yeah and I was freaking out
Ken I was like we're gonna make hundreds
of dollars it's not life-changing money
right now interest rates all right you
know but over four percent for a savings
account so right now is really one of
the best times to save up for a house
obviously house prices are crazy so it's
kind of a wash but you know when you're
making four percent of your money
guaranteed and it's safe and FDIC
insured you sleep easy at night that's
right I want to stay here for a second
because I think there's some some
questions that people have we see it
certainly in our FPU classes we hear
from time to time so for new folks or
for people that are in this situation
right now they're going okay
um I'm not at baby step five yet four
five six is four is 15 percent of your
income towards retirement baby step five
is the funding College there is a point
of no return where we say all right and
I want you to walk through the nuances
of that because I think that that's
important if you've only got four years
oh yeah you understand what I'm saying
so you're late to this well the point of
investing is for that money to make
money and if you don't have time for the
compound growth to happen and the stock
market could go down in two years with
that short of a time frame you may just
want to park it in a savings account
because Junior's going to go to college
in a year or two we gotta be prepared
and make a plan with them so our window
there is less than five years is that
about right less than five years you
know you could see that money take a dip
right over five years chances are you've
made at least some that's right so less
than five years before kiddos going to
college you just want to park that in a
cash account and not invest that because
you just have too much risk I just
wanted to point that out that's a good
call because that is important for a lot
of parents and Junior can work by the
way and they can apply for scholarships
and grants but the key is to have a
conversation to make a plan and don't
just assume yep good stuff there thank
you so much for the call Casey and
George good stuff there all right don't
move more of your calls coming up he's
George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell is
this hour the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're talking about your life
through the lens of your money your work
and your relationships all three of
those areas of your life are connected
if you want to be winning in one of them
you need to be winning in all of them
and we are taking your questions triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you got a work question an income
question uh I specialize in that area
and if you've got your money question
George is the Mack Daddy over here on
that do you even know that phrase I I've
heard it I've never been described as a
Mack Daddy in any show you're about to
be a daddy so I think it applies I
appreciate that how how's your nerves
how are your nerves doing with being a
you know we're about two months out and
so it's starting to feel real you're
gonna be a girl Dad yeah that's exciting
I am very excited but I'm gonna be
honest my lack of sleep is already kind
of I can't wait I can't wait for you to
walk in and sit down next to me and try
to put a sentence together I'm going to
be a zombie yeah you are you're going to
be fine though you're gonna make a great
zombie all right so George I've got
another Trend uh it just feels like the
trends are everywhere you are a
community guy no I'm not but you have a
line about the trends oh that's right
let's let's deliver your signature line
and then I'm gonna tee you up to comment
on one of these trends go George if you
follow the trends you'll fall for the
traps folks that's why who he is and you
love alliteration Ken I knew you the
whole thing makes me happy because
you're right and it sounds good well and
it summed up what a lot this entire
generation what they're doing they're
looking for the latest Trend because
they want to build wealth way too fast
or you know have a shortcut yeah to
avoid pain and it ends up being a trap
well I I want to throw a trend at you
that you're already aware of but I think
it has now reached ridiculous
proportions
a friend of ours a mutual friend of ours
Andy Barton the OG was out shopping
recently and saw this picture I will
describe it for our listening audience
guys let's throw this picture up for our
YouTube and viewing audience and we'll
see this picture on the screen there it
is it's in a Walmart that's in a Walmart
and you've got several cases of of
Coca-Cola in fact those are 24 packs
good Heavens that's a lot of coke and uh
and you can see there it the rollback
price it was 12.58 for this uh it is now
rolled back there to
11.28 but can you can you can you zoom
in there guys I don't know if we can I
have it here you've got it right next to
it it says easy monthly payments with a
firm you can pay over three six or 12
months no hidden fees three now I want
to hit this
three six or 12 months you can Finance
your Coke or is it payments I can't it's
all blurry but then maybe it doesn't
matter
of a dollar each to cover of a dollar
each a pack of Coke to cover something
that's going to be gone in a week oh my
God George
the mentality of the Walmart Shopper
going like hey put it on my tab because
I'm assuming tell me if I'm incorrect
I'm assuming that the reason Walmart's
offering this is because people are
taking them up on it oh 100 well here
please tell me you're buying more than
one case though yeah and as absurd as
that is I've been to Walmart I think
most people buying a pack of Coke
they're buying a few packs of Coke
they're gonna run through that thing
pretty quickly are you are you taking
shots at the Walmart I'm just saying
that the soda lovers out there they love
them you don't just get 124. I mean 24
cans is a lot you need 48
I mean that's too much sugar for a
little guy you need 64. that'd be
comatose oh man but here's the fun fact
for you Ken I dug into this on my
podcast the fine print turns out on
Clara's website they brag that hey
companies businesses if you use our buy
now pay later service on your website
the average store order will shoot up by
45 right because people are buying in
bulk now so people go well Ken there's
no fees there's no interest how am I
getting screwed here uh it's yourself
that's what's happening here you're way
over spending because you don't feel the
payment when you get to pay 25 of it
today and another 25 next month and next
month it's just and next month so well
this is nothing new in 2022 folks listen
to this the share of online purchases
using buy now pay later grew by 14
compared to 2021. this is from Adobe
Analytics
um
but now George
as you said
the piper has come calling yeah let's
always do uh buy now pay later orders
growing 40 in the first two months of
this year compared with a year earlier
and now these users uh which accounted
for some 70 percent of consumer
borrowers between the first quarter of
2021 and the first quarter of 2022 were
11 percentage points more likely
to have a delinquency of at least 30
days on their credit records compared to
non by now pay later borrowers so these
are these are I don't know how else to
say it these are the most egregious
borrowers they're getting in more
trouble than your regular borrower of
course they're just going whatever throw
it in the buggy well whatever it sounded
like a good idea to just put those
things on payments is now becoming oh I
actually can't afford this I thought I
could afford that payment next month and
it turns out I can't and now I'm
delinquent and it's affecting your
credit and you know that we are we are
not fans of the credit score here but a
bad score can't hurt you yeah and that's
a huge problem for so many Americans and
I called this out Ken in our January
Building Wealth event I said mark my
words the biggest trend of 2023 is going
to be buy now pay later exploding yeah
as more and more people are broke
inflation and the cost of living is so
high Ken what else are we supposed to do
put those purchases on payments and kind
I just say this is not People's rent and
food we're talking about some frivolous
purchases here some consumer spending
this is the only thing that would make
this more frivolous if that was beer
agreed you know I mean the coke I mean
come on you're you're gonna buy now
you're gonna buy your Buzz now and pay
later yeah you see what I did there that
was pretty good yeah I like that you're
giving them taglines don't don't help
yeah yeah some marketer out there went
did you hear what they're going on the
Ramsey shows then we're gonna borrow
that you know but listen here's the deal
these folks are going to be in
delinquency and then then it just
creates more and more and more stress
and and the thing is
these companies aren't going to quit
this no and we're only seeing the share
increase and apple just launched their
own Apple pay later which is their
version of this buy now pay later scheme
and I'm telling you America please do
not use these under the guise of well
it's better than a credit card because
there's no interest there's no fees well
a lot of them do have some real sneaky
fine print and let me remind you the
biggest issue I have with this is not
the fees and interest it is the fact
that you're spending 45 percent more
statistically by doing this and because
you see that you don't see a hundred
dollars you see oh it's just 25 now Ken
right what a deal I'll add some more to
the cart I'll have flexibility in my
budget Financial breathing room that's
what these companies are marketing well
let's talk about the game
I mean these companies are in it because
they're winning the game billions of
dollars okay so so how's it play out why
are they in this why is Apple jumping in
this why why why is Apple is becoming a
fintech company they're becoming a
financial company right first then
technology that's right I mean they're
worth 2.6 trillion dollars right and so
they're going they're following the
money and they can't innovate on
products fast enough you know so they're
going to where else can we make money oh
uh we'll have a high-yield savings
account if you have our credit card you
have access to this amazing four percent
uh interest rate then they have Apple
pay later as part of their ecosystem to
keep you in their ecosystem and then all
these companies clarna affirm you've
heard of these companies they're making
fistfuls of cash because the companies
that use them the businesses the
clothing websites Walmart they're paying
a firm and clarina to use that service
right because Walmart knows it's going
to increase the store order by 45 are
you seeing who's winning here everyone
but you American right you're this is
part and they're coming after you by the
way they will come after you yeah if you
don't pay they're gonna come after you
and and I think that that's what people
need to understand I don't know what the
psychology is there to where you go
again you go up there and you go well
imagine you wanted to watch it and it
said 75 off everything in the store
right that's the marketing yeah that's
the number you end up seeing is it's 75
off I only make one payment today and
I'll make three more later right I don't
have the money later right but then life
happens and you realize you had 17
different purchases that you couldn't
keep track of now you overdrafted
getting hit with overdraft fees
why someone want that many things a Coke
that they'll pay later are they thinking
they're getting a deal I don't get it I
don't know Ken at this point you know
trying to understand the American
Consumer and how out of control they are
is beyond me wow but don't fall for this
stuff guys pay for it with cash how's
that for a concept yeah you'll never be
broke if you do that yeah I mean enjoy
that coke with no guilt you know Buzz
free buzz free debt free buzz free debt
free buzz free that's our mantra today
he's George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation about your life your money
your work your relationships here on the
Ramsey show if you're new welcome aboard
we have a lot of people joining us all
the time and so if you're new to the
show Once you go to ramseysolutions.com
and click get started that'll allow you
to kind of plug into what we talk about
here and get an idea where you are in
the landscape understand some of the
things we say so that as you're
listening along
uh you feel like you have caught up
again that is ramseysolutions.com and
click on get started also if you're
enjoying the show please consider
subscribing
writing is a kind review and sharing the
show with a friend Doria is up in Reno
Nevada Doria how can we help
hi there hi how are you
I'm well thank you great what's going on
well I that like some advice on buying a
coastal vacation home and then renting
it out part of the year I'm single so I
need somebody to bounce it off of and
let me know if I could do it or not all
right well your wing men today that's
exactly right so do you have any debt at
all
I don't and I have no credit because I
have no no death well George is very
happy right funny how that works
so are you do you have a home right now
in Reno
I do yes yes okay and is that paid for
yes it is awesome way to go you've done
so well what's the home worth
um probably around
330k okay and what's your income
I get
46.46 a month for my pension
4 600
yes okay so you're no longer working
you're retired you're going hey I want
to vacation home I want to enjoy it but
why not rent it out and make some extra
money is that the idea correct okay
where's the vacation home gonna be
I'm thinking along the Gulf Coast of
Texas okay and what would that cost have
you started doing some research
I have
um gosh anywhere from 300
000 uh upwards to seven which I can't
afford okay and how much money do you
have saved that's non-retirement
non-pension
I've got um about 500 000 in Investments
cash wow how'd you do that
I haven't really
eventual advisor that's awesome well
you've done really really well so you
are you willing to put all 500 of that
towards this investment property
I think well to me it's filled it up
again it's more about your goals because
truthfully those Investments if they're
making on average you know say eight or
ten percent I mean you could pull in 30
40 50k a year just from that investment
yeah which may do better than your
vacation rental business that you're
trying to start and so I wouldn't look
at it Apples to Apples I would go hey I
really want a vacation home and I'm
willing to take the risk on what if no
but what if there's vacancy what if it
doesn't make that much money would you
be okay with that
and I got lost I'm sorry it doesn't make
that much money yeah just think about
the risk when it comes to real estate
just like there is with the stock market
and the the risk is what if there's
vacancies what if people don't book it
what if I can't get what I thought I
could get for it
got it yeah I'd be okay with that
because I'm doing fine now off my
pension okay and that's another reason
why I want you to pay cash for this
investment property because truthfully
this thing's a toy it's a luxury and I
don't want you to go in debt for a toy
and set back what could be a great
retirement and now all of a sudden
you're wondering how I'm going to pay
this mortgage because I thought I could
rent it for this much and oh my gosh
there's another pandemic nobody's
renting and I'll tell you right now Ken
and I were just looking at a really
scary article about Airbnb Revenue
collapse happening
oh revenues are down about 50 percent
that's right in big major cities and
that's worrisome for a lot of folks out
there who have big mortgages on these
airbnbs they got because they thought it
was a money making scheme because they
saw a tick tock and they saw some real
estate Guru on Instagram tell them how
great of an idea was yeah so you're
doing it the right way so far I just
don't want you to get starry-eyed by
going I'm going to have someone else pay
this thing off for me it's gonna be a
scheme versus you saying hey I really
want a vacation home and if I can make a
little bit of money doing the rental
stuff that's great too I would approach
it with that mentality
okay that surprises me the answer yeah
well the the what did you think we were
going to say
um drain my investment and pick it I
love that idea because I know I can get
a much better deal well here's the other
version of this you could just rent a
vacation home anywhere in the world
whenever you want and you just pay for
it
and if that's two weeks out of the Year
versus sinking all this money into it
and we love real estate around here
don't get me wrong I just want you to do
it for the right reasons and if some
people just don't want to have the
hassle of it because either you have to
manage it long distance or you have to
hire a property management company and
hope they have a good head on their
shoulders and hope no one destroys the
place and hvac's out now we gotta you
know out of pocket six grand for that
and when I'm in retirement I just don't
want to have to deal with all that stuff
what and that's the question Doria I
think George has framed this beautifully
so do you want to do this so that you
have a place to retreat to an old if I
can rent it out and it pays for itself
blah blah blah blah blah or is it I just
think this is a better investment of my
money than keeping it in my current
Investments with this financial advisor
who you really like and you guys have
done a good job what is it a or b
oh good point yes
well what is it
oh you're asking
um yeah it's multiple choice there's no
wrong answer but which what what where
are you most motivated this might change
five minutes from now but I think it's
an important exercise why do you want
the home is it for you and then we'll
rent it a little bit or is it just I
thought this was a good investment idea
I think it's because I I want it from me
then I I gotta tell you I would consider
George's idea you're winning financially
like big time you should just pick a new
fun place to go
for two weeks every year and pay cash
and then you leave all the problems
behind
well thank you that's what I would do if
I were you based on that answer based on
your answer and run the numbers out with
your financial advisor sit down with
them and say hey what could this
investment do give me a low end give me
a high end right over the next five
years and then let's play out the
scenario where I buy this investment
property with cash what could that do
low end and high-end and that will start
to give you a picture and talk to people
who actually own vacation property who
rent it out yes oh that's good that's
another thing is this is my personal
vacation home and now strangers are in
there day in and day out messing with it
yeah some people aren't comfortable with
that yeah so that's good I I you gave me
the idea on that to ask that question
because it really does come down to what
are we driving at and if it's just I
want to place down on the Texas Gulf
Coast to stay well guess what you can
try a new place all the time one of
these we love about 30A for our family
is is we go down all the time and we
stay in a different house it's kind of
fun it's like oh we we get to try this
house this year and then this house and
you know and and again you have no
problems it's not your problem you go in
you have a great relaxing week or if
it's two weeks and then you leave and
it's like I'm not worried about it it's
not my issue well and when you have
number one the risk of a mortgage on
that property with that toy you also run
the risk of what if there is vacancy and
what if we can't book it for those three
weeks now we're stressing out about a
problem that we wouldn't have had if we
did it the right way so we're gonna do
this do do with cash well you talked
about this and I I want to bring it back
up I mean we saw an article we'll talk
more about it probably later this week
but but there is a big big foreclosure
risk wave coming with people who they've
watched an Instagram uh they watch The
Tick Tock they did no money down or very
little money down and we are seeing the
uh the VRBO or the Airbnb rates uh this
particular article uh they are
Contracting there's too much too many
houses
and so now people are going to get stuck
and they couldn't afford it without
renters and when renters don't show up
guess what happens you you give
foreclosed on and now you're really in
big trouble so it's going to be great
for for people who want to go get a
really good rate on an Airbnb right now
I was looking at fall break in a certain
place in America and I was I couldn't
believe the rates now I understand it
rates are dropping because again the the
demand is so yeah is so little compared
to this which is a reminder don't
believe this myth that well the renter
is just going to pay the mortgage so why
wouldn't I do this this is a no-brainer
Ken life doesn't work out like that and
on paper it may look good in a perfect
scenario but we live in a fallen world
and we just can't rely on that and so I
want you to do all these moves with a
whole lot of peace and less risk yes
George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman good
hour George thank you so much my friend
one of thanks to uh big Austin in there
keeping us afloat and the guys behind
the glass uh hey you America is why
you're why we do this show
you can win and we're here to help you
win this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay wedding go
to ramseysolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
toll-free number for you to jump in it
is your show America we're here to help
you
I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell joins me
and we will walk through your money
questions your work related questions
maybe you want to Pivot maybe you want a
promotion uh you're wanting to raise
you're trying to figure out what should
I launch the side hustle do I go all in
on it those work related questions I'm
here to help on those and George will
lead us on the money questions triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to Saratoga New York uh the
site of I believe a very famous
Revolutionary War battle the Battle of
Saratoga George I always learned so much
when I'm hanging out with you yeah I've
decided I'm going to start doing it
until they make me stop but a little bit
of uh historical connection to the city
where people call in from am I getting
the thumbs up in there is they they
don't like that they love it I'm going
to keep doing it I'm getting more thumbs
up than thumbs down so Zach go pound
sand thank you very much uh Mark is
there mark how can we help
all right guys thanks for taking my call
you bet
um I'm 24 years old married uh my wife
and I have a two year two to be
two-year-old
um my wife and I handle our finances
separately
um she kind of has her own thing she's
got quite a bit of student loan debt
she's got a really good job she does
that I have no debt I have a four-year
degree uh or no student loan debt but I
have 25 000 in credit card debt
um I have a pickup truck that's fully
paid off I paid cash for it um brand new
about six years ago and I'm wondering if
I should sell the truck
um pay off the debt or if there's a
a hang on a new car loan and just have
the one payment versus having multiple
credit cards
different things and kind of maxed out
on a credit card
which is the better way to help improve
the credit score so that we can
hopefully get in and combine our
finances and go get a house
there's a lot going on here my friend
but I think you're well you're well
aware of that I mean it started with my
wife's got her own thing going on and
then it's we're going to move this to
another kind of debt and we want the
credit score so let's walk through this
step by step the 25 000 is what kind of
debt
it's credit card all credit cards and
what is your income
um so it was about 60 to 80 000
um and now I've played professional
sports in the minor leagues and now I'm
transitioning to kind of getting out of
the career of that and tutoring that so
right now I'm about 35 to 50 000. so are
you doing that part time
yeah it's full time but it's kind of the
writing's on the wall so you know you're
trying to get out of it are you in
baseball
so what is the next
thing for you have you looked into a
different career path
yeah and that's kind of the hard
decision because there's jobs out there
that I know I've been offered and
they're pretty good money and I could
take that next chapter but it's also the
you know the possibility of a high-end
income of continuing to Chase the Dream
is still in play so it's kind of that
the dream being sold yeah baseball so
Major League Baseball we're talking
about big time here so are you are you
double a triple A what's your situation
yeah for the last you know I've played
since I was in high school so yeah we're
we're close but we're we've had a hinder
this past year I got injured and we're
coming back and playing not affiliated
anymore so we're trying to get back into
it um but yeah that's the that's the
unknown of all unknowns well the reason
I ask is is because I've got uh I had
some buddies I'm much older than you now
but I had some buddies who went after it
they made it up to double a ball
um and they had some injuries and at
some point you said earlier in this call
the handwriting is on the wall and then
you said about a minute later but I
don't necessarily want to give up on the
dream and I think that you know this is
your shot you got one shot at this and
once you walk away from it your chances
go way way way down and so um you know I
think you're gonna have to decide here
on that point I'll give I want to give
it back to George on the money thing
there's a lot going on but I think at
some point you're gonna have to decide
um what can I do while still trying to
stay with the dream you know what does
that look like how can I make the most
money in the off season how much longer
am I going to give it and I think that's
got to play into all of this
you know part-time whenever I can just
to honestly pay my debt good um so I'm
making minimums which is frustrating
because I see them paying minimums and
then you see the balance go up and
what's the interest on this credit card
um so it's three different car well it's
two cards that are personal loan
um the person alone was very the birth
of my son
um and then the two credit cards are
they're they're not six so they're
anywhere between 15 and 22.
okay so the way I see it right now as of
what you described I'm looking at
basically a single guy making 35k trying
to pay off 25 000 in credit card debt
with high interest
which is why my wife and I are separate
finances because I don't I my wife's job
is fairly good she has her student loan
she covers that we work together for
rent in doing that but in terms of this
it's like you said I'm looking at the
same way 35 000 well at that point get a
roommate when we got married this is a
team effort man it's both of our incomes
that's the wealth building strategy
no it's my debt her debt her income my
income so what does she make
she's anywhere between 70 and 90 was
commissioned okay and then she asked
just student loan debt
yep and then she makes her car payment
and everything like that so she has a
car loan too
yep and you're talking about selling
your truck but then you're saying I'm
gonna have to go get another car loan
because you don't have any money
well I was more wondering if there's if
it's because with a car loan fixed
interest you know fixed you know percent
in pain it's gonna be much less than the
15 to 20 percent I'm paying with the
credit card and I could start at scratch
with the vehicle but I would be making
probably half the monthly payment yeah
but I don't like just trading one
version of stupidity for another what I
would want to see you do is sell the
truck what can you get for that
about 20. so I can almost cover my debt
so if you sell it for 20 and you take
let's say 10 grand of that and buy a
cash car and use the other 10 to knock
down the debt that gets you further
without going further into debt
yeah so that's what I would do I'd go
buy a beater car if you're going to sell
that truck uh it doesn't free up a
payment so but it does give you 10 grand
to throw at this and start making some
Headway the other problem is your income
we've got to double that income ASAP and
that might mean three jobs and really
better yet it means having a hard
conversation with your wife and going
hey I'm sorry I have not been a great
team player we've got to do this thing
together and I'm willing to show you and
prove to you that I can be trustworthy
with money and I want to tack this debt
together because I know we'll go further
faster would she be willing to have that
conversation or she shut this thing down
no we had that conversation and the
frustrating part is you know you're
sitting here relatively Young starting a
family and I have for you to do that was
paid for I have you know the intro to
available funds no car payment all this
I just have this dumb credit card debt
that I spent because I thought I was
going to be making more money you know
years ago we're going to be right back
here if we don't hit the road issue so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna put
both of you through Financial Peace
University on us you've got to convince
her this is worth going through and it's
not about Marc and his decisions it's
about where are we going as a couple as
a family because right now we're just
roommates trying to get by and that's a
plan that will not work good Financial
advice from George there and Mark I've
watched enough baseball to tell you if
you can't hit the curve and you can't
get on base you probably should go ahead
and hang up the cleats
good good paying job I'm telling you you
got to be able to hit the curve you
can't get on base you're not going to
get in today's Major Leagues I watch
Moneyball
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell and we
are here for you this hour the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five now I
don't know how many of you have heard of
the fire movement some of you are going
whoa where is this going what does this
have to do with money well that's an
acronym George it stands for financially
independent
retired early and you know about all
these things your Mr Financial Trend
nothing gets over on you you've read the
blogs I've seen the tweets you've seen
it all and so this is a movement where
people essentially work themselves
to almost exhaustion and Beyond
and the ideas in their 20s and 30s
they're working like crazy socking
everything away saving living on way
less than they make something that we
obviously love
but they have no life
and the idea is is that they never work
again
which is counter-intuitive to what I
believe to be true what we Ramsey
Solutions believe that you were created
to work to contribute if you will and so
uh this is a headline here I've got in
my hands this is a uh make sure I oh
this is a finance uh Yahoo article there
the team hates when I do that guys it's
just an old paper tactic it's going to
be okay it's all right they get so alarm
nobody wants to hear the paper I think
they do I do it on my show all the time
I love it do you guys like the paper
crinkle out there it's it's overwhelming
in the lot the lobby guests are like
Zach likes that one okay very good all
right so here's a story in my hands here
of a couple uh that is now well
shall we say regretting this decision
they retired early George with 4.3
million dollars
but now this is their quote we don't
want to just keep throwing money on the
pile and being cheap so they want to
live but they're afraid to spend and uh
so this is a scarcity mentality that the
the the the man says in the couple this
is Carl and Mindy and um uh they they
retired six years ago with 4.3 million
dollars saved uh and so uh they focused
on doing several things flipping real
estate uh they socked away a bunch of
money they still have a bunch of assets
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
but they're not living in a way that
they would like to
and uh so your thoughts on this George
because I mean this is there's another
story we'll get to this in a second but
I mean this doesn't always work out for
people it sounds great
but then you work and you skip out on so
much life then you're then you're living
life on your terms except except maybe
you aren't well like you mentioned there
is some Crossover with our principles
and the fire movement principles which
is live on less than you make increase
your income invest and save the
difference be on a budget spend wisely
well these people have taken that to an
extreme that is very unhealthy and so
the idea here is hey Ken what if in our
30s we could have three million dollars
and just live off of that and never have
to work a day again here's a problem
with that you could live another 60
years so now you're trying to Penny
pinch to make this millions of dollars
last 60 years while going uh what do we
fill in our time with other than
worrying about money yeah so the idea is
to stop worrying about money and yet
here they are worrying about money
because of a scarcity mentality so we
believe there's a balance there and Ken
of course is always preaching that we
were created to contribute
is that working is actually good for us
and I'm in the boat of uh you know enjoy
your life and so if you have to live
this scarcity mindset life to make it
work so that you can retire from working
for the man it was a bad plan to begin
with that's right and I think retirement
and this may be an unpopular opinion but
I'll put it out there I don't think
retirement
um is what it's cracked up to be if your
whole goal is just to not work as
opposed to how do you want to live like
it's not about not working but that's
for a lot of people what retirement is I
just don't want to work well it should
be about so much more than that and I
think that uh that well I don't think I
know the data uh plays out that when
people stop working for enjoyment
they're not doing something productive
and I'm not talking just hobbies that
your overall health suffers so this idea
that I'm just gonna I'm Gonna Save and
live uh no enjoyment just so I never
have to work again it's never going to
play out well for people in fact in and
financially it doesn't either Sam Dogan
who is one of the you know forefathers
of this movement retired through 11
years ago with three million dollars and
uh big news it's in this article and it
came out probably a couple months ago I
covered on my show that now he's so
worried about being able to pay for the
cost of his kids who are little they're
Toddlers and he's projecting that
tuition which has steadily gone up
uh over the you know last decade that's
going to be so much that he's not gonna
have any money to live off of and so now
he's coming back for one reason only to
cover college education and again
there's no joy there's no as Thomas
Jefferson wrote The Pursuit of Happiness
here it's just that scarcity mindset
well and he says I started doing some
research and learned that happiness is
mostly something that comes from you it
comes from the inside not an external
Factor ah so he figured this out after
some research what Thomas Jefferson uh
there you go new all along so here's
what people long for in retirement is
freedom
I think he should continue to work
you've asked me this before I'm not
going to retire
so what's your what's your long-term
game plan I mean you're nowhere close
you look great you've got the spry 41. I
appreciate that uh but but I I'm am I
going to work less sure will I keep the
hours and and the intensity uh probably
not but but not far off because I
there's at least something as I get
older where I can work and contribute
and see purpose and and experience
meaning and that's good for my overall
health and uh well people have a
negative view of work Ken that's the
problem they're doing something they
hate well that's right uh they're not
doing the right kind of work they're not
doing it at the right place they're
working for the wrong leaders that's
right they're not treated right that's a
very good point there so a lot of
factors that play into this where you're
going hey what if we could find you a
place that you actually enjoy being at
with people you respect with good
leadership and work that you're
passionate about yeah I I remember
meaning uh when we lived in Atlanta I
got to tell you this story about Martha
so Martha was 76 and she worked in the
local Chick-fil-A that we went to with
our kids
a write-off of Peachtree Industrial
Boulevard right there in Suwanee Georgia
all right and I asked her one time she
was so kind and so sweet it was like she
was like everybody's grandma and I asked
her I was like why do you do this she
goes because I just love being here with
people and serving and working in a way
that just makes people feel comfortable
and I know that I'm making a difference
she was always walking around every
table can I get you a refill can I turn
in your children's book for the ice
cream you know these are very important
things that you're going to be dealing
with not to talk about that I don't have
kids yet and I still do that you always
go get the ice cream that's my hack uh
so so it's it's and she just said I just
love showing up and being a part of this
team that's the idea and she did it part
time you know not because she had to
because she wanted well you've asked
this question Ken what would you do if
money was was not a factor yeah that
gets you dreaming and usually whatever
that thing is
it involves making money you can make
good money doing that it does and here's
the other thing in retirement when if
you've lived like no one else so later
you can live and give like no one else's
we teach you you won't need the money
but you you'll need the engagement you
go do that then you've got extra money
you've got that extra spending money you
don't even it's just what are you doing
you can give it away you do a lot of fun
things and I think that that's really
important so there's a lot of themes
here generosity being one of generosity
is a huge people that's the key to Joy
not consuming and trying to achieve some
level of wealth the other one is
contentment and the other one is
moderation going hey maybe it's not good
for us to spend everything we make and
be broke maybe it's not good for us to
live on so little that we live in a
scarcity mentality on the fritz all the
time maybe we should just be on a budget
and assign some line items for things
like vacations and things like eating
out you can do that once you're out of
debt and let's have a plan to retire
with some dignity to where we can do
some really cool things and take the
kids on Amazing vacations and so I think
our plan has a really nice balanced
approach it really does uh but you know
for a lot of these folks they're going
to look back and go I don't have enough
money and I don't remember doing
anything in my 30s other than working
which by the way are some of your best
years you know health-wise physically
30s 40s career-wise and so to squander
that by trying to get to this goal so
quickly I think hurts people mentally
financially I agree emotionally all of
it you make a good point you know your
30s is still a wonderful decade of
testing I'm in it and Discovery I'm
living it and seeing who you are and
really preparing for that second half of
your life if you're blessed to have that
so really interesting stuff we're going
to walk you through
how to do it in a way that you truly
enjoy your life have some peace and look
back with no regret but you're actually
reminiscing this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
this is where we help you win in your
life your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five George you talk
about this all the time uh protecting
yourself from emergencies in the form of
insurance I mean you're a real Insurance
Guru can I call you that I mean it's
kind of a lame title but I'll take it
because I think it's an underrated
wealth building tool because it protects
all the wealth you're trying to build
that's right and you've taught me this
there's 10 kinds of insurance coverage
you might need based on what your life
looks like today and we've built a tool
called the coverage checkup to show you
which types you need to add drop or
adjust George give us a couple of
examples of some of the ridiculous not
needed insurance coverages my favorite
as of late is alien abduction insurance
right but that's looking like that may
be more and more needed in the all those
reports on UFOs I don't know about the
wrong side of History I I don't know
what to believe here's an unpopular
opinion that has nothing to do with this
conversation there are no aliens whoa
there it is folks have a blast in the
chat room I'll never read your comments
but those of you who think there are I
got news for you they're not we are
alone you are being duped that includes
you Zach he is not liking Today's Show
in the in the control room I just love
that Ken still thinks there's like some
kind of AOL chat room that's kind of the
water cooler of the web that's happening
there's a chat room on YouTube there's a
live chat but calling it a chat room oh
that's very old school oh this is good I
needed to be so what do you call it just
a live chat a live chat versus chat room
me thinks you're splitting hairs young
friend there are no hairs being split
when I think chat room I think AOL chat
rooms from back in the day oh I see okay
well r.i feeling silly but there are no
aliens uh anyway so moving on uh you
don't want alien abduction Insurance
coconut Insurance there's a falling
coconut that's another one
well the list goes on Wow but you don't
have to worry about those Ken just worry
about the ones you actually need things
like Home Auto term life Identity Theft
Protection so we'll walk you through
that in five minutes this is a five
minute tool that makes sure that you
have the right coverage meaning if I
need to add some for protection or I
need to get rid of some that are just
costing me money now I found some money
for my budget I just got a few messages
in the last week of people messaging me
saying hey I took that checkup tool I
reshopped home and auto alone and I'm
saving 600 bucks a year now I'm saving
1300 bucks a year that's good money so
talking about making more income you
might be overpaying for insurance and
that's a great way there you get some
more back in your budget
ramseysolutions.com checkup could be a
way to get a raise
ramseysolutions.com checkup all right
let's go to Oklahoma City Oklahoma area
you know that's where George the
national cowboy museum is did not know
that Adam is there Adam how can we help
hey thanks for taking my call you bet
what's going on
yeah so my question is how do I navigate
being like a Ramsay listener trusting
your advice on money and being a
mortgage loan officer I asked this
because I put people into mortgages that
do not align with what I would do
um I offer helocs all of it that you
don't recommend while I don't do any of
these things how do I get them to people
who ask without feeling guilty
it's a good question and and we've I've
received this question on the show many
times uh and it's it's um first of all
you're not doing anything morally or
ethically wrong let's start there can
you can you acknowledge that
yeah okay so you're in an industry where
again if you don't feel like long term
your values are aligning aligning then
then I think at some point you begin to
make the exit don't you don't need to
jump right away because again you're not
doing anything morally legally ethically
wrong there's just a disconnect when you
see people take out things as you go
this is not good for them but you can't
say that because then you lose your job
and so I think my first reaction to this
is don't jump
Let's Line something else up and let's
do work that that we enjoy but also that
produces a result that aligns with our
values and that's what's happening right
now so I don't want you to beat yourself
up is what I'm saying but eventually
this is going to wear on you and could
create some resentment certainly a toxic
attitude in yourself and so I would
begin to be looking at what can I do
that I align with and the other piece of
this is
we need some good guys out there too
Adam and you're one of the good guys
that's right and so there's nothing
wrong with saying hey you know what I'm
going to pass those loans off to someone
else or I'm going to educate the
customer on my feelings about this and
if they still want to go through with it
at least I can sleep easy at night but
if they are dead set on taking out the
HELOC I'm going to try to serve them
well as they go through this and educate
them and go hey here's what you need to
know about the HELOC here's why I don't
think it may be the right choice for you
and at least then you have your morals
intact and you're not swindling someone
into something but again in the mortgage
industry there's a lot of mortgages we
don't agree with and we've I've got a
lot of friends that are mortgage loan
officers and you know we're fans of the
15-year fixed rate mortgage might they
sell someone a 30-year mortgage because
that's what the customer wants
that's part of the job and so if that's
something that is going to eat you
inside like Ken said then I think it's
time to switch to a different industry
entirely or find a different role
yeah it's just because my parents are
realtors so ever since
I got my license the idea was that all
of their clients would do their
financing through me
so it's just we have our own like you
know place now where it's at a One-Stop
shop for real estate and it works out
really well like that and
I just when I first was getting into it
I never thought that this would even be
an issue because it's just so perfect
and you know it's great money and
everything but I just wish I wasn't so
like encumbered in the renty way
because it just it is you know like
ignorance was Bliss before this and now
I just know how terrible of an idea this
stuff is what do you think about what
George said though Adam I thought his
good guy strategy was pretty good
certainly since your parents are sending
these people your way and so if you're
going look I know you want this but let
me just walk you through every side of
this deal and you give them perspective
yeah see I
I wish I could you know do that with
like if I had a lot of clients I mean
anyone that I get from them if I were to
turn them away I would lose that like
relationship I don't think we said
anything about turning them away the
idea was is just helping them see what
the best vehicle is for them long term
which alone is the best for them
right okay
yeah it's yeah here's the deal we've
covered this from every side and I could
tell you're wrestling with this and my
point is is that if you can't get to a
place where you feel good about this you
need to move on in the future that
that's the takeaway uh because George
it'll eat him up yeah it'll just weigh
on him and it's just not necessary well
in the financial industry is a tough one
to be in if you say hey I have this very
specific view of money uh but I work at
a bank and Banks sell debt products
Banks sell credit cards but guess what
we also need good morally valued people
working in those Banks to serve
customers and so I don't think you're a
bad person for being in this if you stay
there but again if it's something that's
going to affect you personally at some
point it's not worth the money and I'd
rather you go make a little bit less for
now as you go find a different career
path of something that you can really go
I feel really good that I serve that
person well today
yeah because again here's what will
happen
you will just make yourself miserable I
don't care what it is you know you could
do you could have you could be in a in
what I would call The Sweet Spot where
you're using what you do best do what
you love to produce results that matter
to you
and you're in an environment where you
feel like
a leadership is unethical they've done
something that you really disagree with
and it just kind of they smoothed it
over they swept it under the carpet I
don't care what the situation is when
there is a a sizable disconnect in your
values
um
it's different than putting up with a
problem employee or a teammate or even a
boss is just not great but they don't
they're not abusive to you this is a
this is a character ethical excuse me uh
not ethical this is a character or
values based conversation and when it is
so opposed to what you believe you won't
be able to grit your teeth and bear it
for very long I mean it's one reason all
I can't sell cars because I know the
people walking in there right are going
to want to do it and they don't have the
money and I'm gonna have to walk them
through the payments and the debt I
couldn't sleep at night and so I
wouldn't be in that industry because of
my values yeah good stuff hey thanks for
the call Adam you're a good good young
man appreciate the call it's a good call
I think you know what you need to do
let's just do it wisely let's not make
any big jumps don't move folks more of
your calls coming up this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show
conversation about your life
specifically your money your work your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman George
Campbell joins me the phone number to
jump in on the conversation for your
question is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
with 19 service Brands Nationwide you
can find Reliable help from great
locally owned businesses like air serve
Mr Appliance and Mr Handyman visit
neighborly.com today for help with just
about anything for your home today's
question comes from Lauren in Georgia
I was recently given the option of
resigning by the end of the month and
receiving Severance or potentially being
laid off in a couple of months the
company has not been open about what's
going on and I honestly don't know if my
job is safe I have no debt and currently
have 2500 saved for my emergency fund
Severance would be a gross of thirty
five thousand dollars would you
recommend I take the money and find a
new one or stay and see what happens
uh Lauren I would take the money in this
state in this situation because when
when they come to you and say all right
we're giving you two options option one
you're resigned by the end of the month
we give you the severance or you hang
around and you might get laid off
they would prefer for you to
take the severance that tells me
something yeah and uh I can tell you
this you're probably not going to get a
severance if you get laid off
uh the way that this is worded so it
sounds like there's an ultimatum here
yeah and I just don't I don't want to
sit around and just again be waiting for
the shoe to drop you know this is about
quality of life you know am I am I going
to be coming in every day wondering is
today the day I I just know thanks I'm
out I'll bet on me this is a nice
Severance here uh her financial
situation is great she has no debt I'd
like to see you have more savings but
you know what
um let me tell you this even if I didn't
have anything lined up I'd be working
even if it was part-time and keeping
cash flow coming in and just stocking
that up or living off of that and and
not touching as much of that Severance
I'd love to just keep working two jobs
three jobs whatever until I found
something just to not touch that
Severance yeah and this really speeds up
your financial plan oh my God it's not
the ideal circumstances but having an
extra 35 Grand to throw at that 2500 in
savings that'll get you by for a while
while you figure out what's next and
like Ken said in the meantime I'm
starting today and I'm going to be
working part-time and hopefully you'll
get back on your feet soon but this
company is not the long-term place
anyways no and so if they're going to
write you a check to leave I'm taking it
yeah it's you're paying me to leave yes
thank you very much and I'll take the
blender as well uh let's go to Anna next
in New Orleans or some people say Nolans
Anna how can we help hi thank you for
taking my calls you bet what's going on
okay so I'm 21 years old I'm about to be
a senior this coming fall I'll be doing
my teaching residency so that's exciting
um and uh my parents have paid they paid
for all of my colleagues they're big f2u
people they teach you that church and
everything awesome
um so I was wondering I just started
paying for everything besides insurance
on my own so if I rent utilities you
know the basic necessities and expenses
and um I follow a budget I do everything
you know like I'm supposed to but I'm
wondering and I do tie I tied the second
half all of my income comes in but I'm
wondering how do I go like I don't make
that much I kind of make you know I
probably have an extra 400 every single
month after expenses and ties and
everything so I'm wondering how and I
just hit around 600 like for an
emergency fund I just started building
up saving so I'm wondering how I can
bless other people like monetarily when
I don't have that much to blush if that
makes sense yeah that's a great question
wow how to to like go above my ties for
other people because I want to be my
parents are very big givers and I want
to be that way and I'm trying to but I
don't really know how to if that makes
sense how much do you have can we put a
number on this because you sound like
you've got your finances just really uh
buttoned up so what is that small amount
that you're referring to that you could
use to give
groceries and like I have a little
entertainment section and then my
savings after all of that is around four
or five hundred dollars every month and
I usually just put that right into my
emergency fund and whatever else is left
I've just started building up my actual
savings because I've already hit the 500
but I'm trying to build that up to a
thousand as much as I can but I have the
initial 500 so everything that's left
over I've just been putting and saving
right but my question is what's that
number that you would like to give have
you got a because I feel like you've got
a number in your head based on what you
set the question up
yeah probably I don't know I mean it
doesn't have to be anything like crazy
just because I don't you know make too
much money anyway but I want to find
ways and I do like try to bless other
people like helping them and things like
that but how can I like you know I'm
trying to find ways of things you know
within range probably less than a
hundred dollars okay
that's all I was looking for well I hope
you'll be freed up by this motto I
believe our friend Rachel Cruz coined it
maybe I have no idea maybe it's a famous
philosopher but it's give a little until
you can give a lot and that's exactly
your plan right now and some I think
what you're asking for is what are some
ways I can do that tactically and one
way is I call it kind of a bless up fund
and in your budget you can have a line
item under giving that's just kind of
bless up and you've got a hundred
dollars allocated as the spirit leads
you that month if there's just an
amazing server at the restaurant that
person on the corner uh you know with
the sign whatever that is maybe it's a
friend who goes hey I need the car
repair this month is killing me and you
leave an anonymous envelope of cash at
their door so what it allows you to do
when you're not broke is be looking
upward and outward to go what are the
opportunities in my community in my
friend group and my family to be
generous and I would set that goal of a
hundred dollars a month is where I'm
going to start once I get up to you know
over a thousand dollar emergency fund
and I get this other goals set I'm going
to increase that even more and so making
it a habit is a great great thing to do
and there's probably opportunities you
know through your local church as well
to give beyond the tithe maybe there's a
mission opportunity I know we've started
different Ministries at our church for
foster care and buying cars for single
moms and gifting them to them so find
something that you're passionate about
our friends at charity water Scott
Harrison they're doing amazing work and
you can give monthly to support their
work across the world in getting people
clean water so I would make it from the
heart and something you're passionate
about yeah I agree with George uh the
only thing I'd add to what he said is I
I'd have that 100 maybe on you and and
and be intentional to go okay I've got
30 days to give it away you know if
we're going to do this monthly and and
just be present I I think just you know
and again everything George said I
completely agree so you could pick
something or you could do this or you
could do a combination but I just like
the idea of you walking around antenna
up
and looking for opportunities to go you
know what I see a little kid riding down
the street and he's got a flat tire you
know and he oh can I help you know well
I can't yeah I'm making this up this is
a horrible example but yeah it is you
know you is a single mom and you go buy
a bike tire for that kid in that single
month I'm I'm telling you like
and that just came to my head but that's
the idea of where I am my antenna is up
and I'm looking for an opportunity to
just blow somebody away you know a
single mom who slammed at a restaurant
that you're eating maybe you're eating
with your mom and dad and your mom and
dad tip him tip her and you go you know
what I'm gonna go all 100 I'm gonna put
my 100 on there for this single mom you
know it's just being present and I think
that will make you so aware uh and
that's the real Joy of giving is being
aware and stepping into the moments that
I believe God puts us on these people's
paths I love that so I love your spirit
that's amazing let me just like I wish
we could clone you and have you all over
the world we could change some things in
this country it's so true you were how
old did you say
I'm 21 21. imagine how generous she's
gonna be when she's got a huge income
and a pile of money because money makes
you more of whoever you already are yeah
yeah and so it's just a magnifying glass
and when you're when you're a broke jerk
you become a rich jerk and when you're
Anna and you're 21 and you have a
hundred dollars to give and you're just
so excited to give that when you've got
a thousand when you got ten thousand
we're gonna change some lives so I'm so
proud of you yes what we're talking
about here is planned generosity versus
spontaneous generosity and I believe
both have both of us in the budget they
do wow what a bright like don't tell me
that the future can't be bright there
are some just great young people who get
it and they're doing something about it
that is great and Mom and Dad went
through Financial Peace University did
you hear that that helps Morris coffin
Todd and she's catching it a lot of
there's some trickle-down economics for
you go look that up some of you people
don't even know what that phrase means
George Campbell grayed out stuff I think
Austin and the crew behind the glass
keeping us on the air in new America for
listening this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsaysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me this
hour the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five George take your money questions
I'll chime in and then I'll take your
work related questions want to Pivot
want a promotion you feel stuck what do
I do I don't make more money should I
launch the side hustle all those
questions I'll take those and George
chimes in on those so we are here for
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five let's go to Christopher in the
City of Brotherly Love that's
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Christopher
how can we help
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call you bet what's up
been a little bit of a dilemma uh really
just torn
um so my wife and I are expecting a baby
in August and um it's our first and
we're super excited super nervous we're
working the baby steps we've paused the
baby steps
my wife was going to be getting six
weeks off of work my company is offering
12 weeks unpaid
um when the baby's due if she comes when
she's due we're going to have about
seven eight thousand State on top of our
starter emergency fund
and um I was planning to take three
weeks off by the closer and closer we
get to the due date I just I really want
to take more time and just enjoy this
new experience but I'm also torn because
that means I'm out of work longer so I
guess the question is should I just
stick to my three week plan get back to
work or would it be okay for me to dip
into that extra money so that I can
afford to take more weeks off because we
are planning to dump that extra money on
debt
okay and is she planning on taking just
the six weeks and then going back to
work or is she going to take further
unpaid time what's her plan
so that is an option
um but right now they're offering six
weeks if she has a natural birth and age
if she has a C-section so it's probably
going to stay within that six to eight
for her okay and you are you thinking
the same for you are you wanting to take
all 12 if you can
um
it's it's odd I don't want to take more
than her I feel like I almost feel wrong
for that but I I feel okay with six
weeks but I also think three weeks isn't
enough so and then what's your plan
beyond that let's say you both go back
to work after six weeks right
uh we just get back to the baby steps
and dump everything except for our
thousand dollar emergency fund back on
debt okay and is it daycare and my
reservation what would the child care
situation be
um her mom is going to be watching her
for a significantly lower price than our
local bakery got it okay that's kind of
a big factor in all of this is what is
the child care situation look like and
then the second piece is financially
what can you afford to do without
setting yourself back financially so you
have somebody how much debt do you have
uh currently about 75 000 and consists
of student loans and car loans soon to
be paid off okay and then what is the
household income
uh gross is about 105 to 110 a year
awesome and you'd have a few you you'd
uh dip down on that while you were
unpaid for potentially a few weeks
yep okay I guess it's more of like a I
don't I know that that money is supposed
to be put back on debt when mom and baby
are home and healthy but I also know
that if I take if we take everything
except for a thousand and actually three
weeks for me unpaid isn't realistic
um
well I wouldn't do it could you sell one
of the cars if this is a big dream for
you
potentially yeah I mean it's tough
because my wife uses
one of the cars for work and it would
make it really difficult for me to get
to and from work well what's it worth
versus the loan on it
um it's worth about 7 500 and we have 3
100 left on it okay so probably not
worth selling to make three grand if it
was if the numbers were different I
would say hey if you can make 10 grand
on this car and get something cheaper
and get rid of the payment that could
help but the numbers here don't make it
worth it
right can do you have to decide right
now or can you go hey I'm gone for two
weeks I'm gonna come back next week
it's not like I have to give them a
really long notice mine
my district manager is all for me taking
extra time and he you know I can let him
know pretty last minute if I wanted to
okay yeah I might play it by ear I'm
gonna take you know commit to the two or
three weeks and beyond that say I'm
probably coming back to work but we're
gonna have to play it by ear and see you
know how mom and baby are doing and how
I'm feeling about this and where we're
at financially and if we can take this
hit
yeah I I'm gonna take a much more uh I
don't know what the what the adjective
is here I wouldn't go back financially
at all for this not one penny I wouldn't
uh now if mama and baby aren't healthy
and there's a whole different situation
but if everything's okay dude get back
to work after three weeks I mean three
weeks is nice I mean the baby doesn't
even remember you're fine I I would not
suffer going backwards at all
financially for this three weeks is
enough for for the dad in this situation
that's a very nice nice uh benefit
that's just me uh but I got three kids
so you know I mean there's gonna there's
a point in time where they don't even
want to talk to you uh so at this point
I I wouldn't I wouldn't go backwards
financially me personally I would not do
that I don't think it's going to be
worth it I really don't
um
okay
but I'm I know I'm a little bit more old
school George is a little bit more you
know in touch with what I'm happy with
it but also you know if it was unpaid
that's a different situation so you know
I'm I'm in a very similar situation as
you Christopher where I'm going to be
having a baby first in August so we're
gonna be right alongside each other
having a good time and I plan on taking
two weeks off but you know it's all it's
all very squishy here for the guys in a
lot of companies as far as parental
leave goes and so I'm gonna go as long
as I can but we've got Live Events we've
got work to do and so I'm gonna go back
to work as soon as I need did I
understand this correctly he gets three
weeks paid
is that right
uh it's unpaid unpaid three weeks is
what we've already planned for
eign
at all I wouldn't take any of the three
weeks I come from a world where when we
had our babies I worked every day and
they walked uphill both ways Christopher
no I'm dead serious I wouldn't even do
that
I wouldn't do that you'll be fine I
wouldn't take three weeks of unpaid
leave
the baby's fine the Mama's fine I don't
have memory from when I was three I'm
gonna tell you something right now and
I'm not I'm not knocking you if you
decide to do this so I'm having some fun
with this but I'm deadly serious about I
wouldn't take any time off if you didn't
have it
not in this situation because you're
going to go backwards financially is it
going to break you no
so it's your call and I'm not judging
anybody well if you guys run a different
place financially the answer might be
different if you had zero dead huge
emergency fund but because of the
situation man I want to get to safety
when I'm bringing a baby into this world
I want to have some Financial business
you're not taking any time off it's up
to me yeah you'll be fine okay you'll be
fine
you'll survive it either way but I'm
excited for you man very good thank you
appreciate the call George I got to tell
you I I I might it changed it for you
when it was unpaid 100 that's a three
weeks if not of not getting that
paycheck like I feel like I could say
this and if this offends some people
they can get over it I don't know why
dudes need to be taking maternity leave
uh what is it called paternity yeah for
the dudes no stop it go to work you had
nothing to do with it Ken I had
something to do with it but I'm just
saying I I need to be at work forget it
I don't get it we all survived just fine
this is the softening of America I don't
get it Philadelphia Cream Cheese over
here again yes
I'm gonna hear it for that this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back America you have joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by George Campbell
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five
two two five all right headline here
Money Talks news this is the article
headline could new legislation hurt your
credit card rewards a group of lawmakers
and lobbyists are gearing up to battle
over a proposal that could change the
way credit card transactions get
processed and possibly up in the credit
card reward system I know that's going
to kill you George you know you like
those points love my miles you know me
the credit card competition Act was
introduced last week by bipartisan group
of legislators by the way bipartisan
means Dems and Republicans just making
sure people understand just a little
civics lesson
um and they were led by Senator Dick
Durbin out of Illinois and this is the
second time he has proposed this bill
did not go anywhere the first time and
uh so uh what is it uh the details of
the bill are all about network access
and credit card transactions basically
every time you use a credit card at a
store or online the bank that issued you
the card charges the merchant a fee and
this is called an interchange or swipe
fee the amount of the fee is set by the
card processor like Visa or Mastercard
the merchants have no say in the matter
because visa and MasterCard dominate the
network so often the merchants pass the
fees on to customers and that in turn
leads to inflated prices now if this is
past George it would require the
nation's biggest card issuing Banks to
offer a second smaller Network
the opportunity to compete for
transactions there we go the idea here
is is that by bringing competition in
visa and MasterCard would have to start
lowering their prices in order to get
business Merchants benefit and then
theoretically and I I stress the word
theoretically
they could pass along the savings to
others or to as many unsuspecting buyers
that are out there George just keep that
Nifty little fee tucked down there
towards the bottom of the receipt so
um
how could it affect credit card rewards
one estimate predicts that this would
save Merchants about 11 billion dollars
annually wow and uh
and so uh the the hotly debated
consequence would involve the rewards if
retailers are able to select which
processor they want uh the rationale
says they're likely to go for the
cheaper option and I could set off a
chain reaction hurting Visa and
Mastercards profits I know but here I
get it but then they start slashing the
points programs so there you go because
that's partially how credit card
companies give you all the rewards when
you swipe fat profits means they give
some rewards if you eat into their
profits they're going to go sorry George
your miles program cut in half
I mean just economically speaking saving
Merchants 11 billion dollars what would
that do for the economy what would that
do for prices that you all are
complaining are so inflated
well let's think about small businesses
yeah small businesses paying the extra
three percent because you swiped your
credit card right and they got to pass
that on or eat it either way not good
for the rest of us no and so this is one
of the reasons I hate credit card Awards
Ken the people swiping the card are the
same people on the other side of this
complaining about inflation and inflated
prices and I'm going you caused that
yeah and I actually have the numbers
here if you're interested I know I love
numbers and I love legislation here are
the as of 2023 what card issuers are
charging Merchants per transaction okay
so every you know transaction you spend
a hundred dollars Visa charges that
business owner 1.4 to two and a half
percent MasterCard one and a half to two
point six percent discover one and a
half to two and a half percent you're
gonna love this one American Express 2.3
to three and a half percent there you go
and then you wonder why businesses have
little signs that say we do not accept
American Express right because they're
getting screwed every time you use that
card and they've got to dish out three
and a half percent that's three dollars
and fifty cents for every hundred
dollars yeah they're losing yeah and so
that which adds up as you can see here
11 billion annually is what merchants
would get back so I'm a fan of this bill
okay I'm not gonna go that far because I
don't have the bill in front of me and
who knows what's in this bill but I like
that competition will be uh created
because competition always serves the
customer agree when you have monopolies
or a couple of big dogs kind of
strangers have been running the show for
too long they set the bar and I like
competition I also like
giving small businesses more money back
that's good for all of us consumers so
think about that if prices if prices
come
to percent guess what that means you'll
have two percent more that's right in
your budget we go we get your own
rewards we hope not all companies pass
that saving back on to us the customer
but I hope so on the surface I like the
bill and I love hearing you say that you
support the bill and that's what America
is waiting I love when you get involved
in uh consumer politics uh this is all
about your pocketbook pocketbook
politics how about that pocketbook
politics you just gave someone who's
much smarter than me a great book idea I
might have all right let's go to Brandon
in Minneapolis Minnesota Brandon how can
we help
so I made the mistake of taking out a
loan and buying a new truck a couple of
years ago and so I know I'm not supposed
to take funds out of my 401k but I've
been doing my best to not tap into my
HSA
on all the medical expenses you know
I've paid out of pocket so far but I
only have about 9 500 left on the loan
and I'm slated to pay that off probably
within the next three four months
with everything I'm slapping at it but
could I take money out of my HSA because
I really want to start contributing to
15 to my 401k
I think this is a bad plan man
do not Rob yourself
because this is a non-medical purpose
well but I'm just saying like from all
the bills that I paid out of my pocket
so far I'd be just reimbursing myself
from the money you contributed to it
no no from all the medical expenses that
I've paid out oh I see so you'd say hey
I'm gonna I'm gonna actually submit the
medical expenses and get reimbursed for
this
correct versus leaving the money in
there it's invested right now
no no I haven't gone that far yet I just
started the whole HSA plan for my first
time last year I'm gonna let the HSA be
for for the HSA needs which is health
and I wouldn't do the whole
reimbursement get the money out I'm just
going to use your future income which I
hope is is nice and high what do you
make
um just shy of 80 000. okay so how
quickly is this truck paid off
yeah I estimate four months love it
so we can survive another four months to
speed this is there anything else you
can do to speed it up outside of Dipping
into your piggy banks and cookie jars
well there are a couple of side hustles
that I could do but they're few and far
between I play the bagpipes so whenever
I can get a gig is that like funerals
and weddings like what are what are the
normal occasions for a bagpipe side
Hustle
yeah typically it's uh weddings and you
know funerals but special events come up
and you know you can charge a premium
for those I like this idea a whole lot
more than dipping into the HSA I love
bagpipes I just want to point that out
you know it's a it's a unique art I'll
say that but typically the most I'd make
on each of these gigs is probably like
300 well outside of that I mean there's
a lot of you know delivery apps and all
kinds of gigs I'm sure you have other
skills what do you do full time
oh I'm basically a glorified auditor
glorified I like that very self-aware
what's a non-glorified auditor
a regular
otter listen man I listen I before it
gets the frozen tundra out there you got
some 15 to 20 to 25 an hour part-time
gigs that are out there where you can
rack up the money quickly I'm just
telling you if you want it you can go
get it
well that sounds like a plan to me I'll
just go ahead and leave the HSA alone do
it and uh wonderful yeah the other piece
of this Brandon is behavior change and
Robin One account to pay the other
account it's not really changing what
got you into this mess and I think doing
those side hustles and the worse they
are the more you're gonna go I'm never
gonna go into debt again that truck loan
was so dumb I should have bought a car I
could afford with cash at the time I'm
never gonna do that again so I'm gonna
use future income to pay for that and
find other ways than dip it in but man
you're on the path four months away
worst case this thing's gone you got it
Brandon stay the course thank you for
the call this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life your money
your work your relationships here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman George
Campbell is my co-host joins me this
hour the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five back at
the first of this year George we told
our audience at the housing market was
not going to have a meltdown and guess
what it didn't now has it slowed down
sure
but one of the changes we've seen is
that homes are taking longer to sell
while buyers and there's plenty of them
shop for homes they can actually afford
this means pricing your home right and
getting it in front of the right buyer
is a big deal that's a lot to do on your
own and you shouldn't be the one
navigating it in the first place it's
not your job you need a real estate
agent who knows your local housing
market inside and out you need a Ramsay
trusted agent by your side these guys
and gals got our team stamp of approval
because they're top tier real estate
agents that you can trust to handle
something this important if you're ready
to sell your home don't settle for
average work with the best of the best a
Ramsey trusted agent go to
ramsesolutions.com agent that is
ramseysolutions.com Agent Adrian is up
in Monterey California Adrian how can we
help
hey I got a question for you guys so
I've been watching her at this show for
about three months now and uh I know you
guys talk about getting out of debt and
debt is or being debt free is great
right
um but one of the things that I kind of
get lost on is um with credit cards I
hear a lot of people say that credit
cards you know you can use them in a lot
of good ways and a lot of bad ways from
what the Ramsey shows explains but my
question is why is it so bad to use
credit cards if you can use them
responsibly I see no issue in using them
to build credit and earn rewards so what
advice can you guys give me
that's a fair question Adrian appreciate
the uh the call today how old are you
23. cool and why are you into this
financial stuff kind of what are your
goals when it comes to money
just where where I came from my parents
you know were not financially educated
and kind of seeing that wanted me to be
a little bit different a lot of my
family is not you know they're not
financially responsible so kind of just
you know one of my good buddies who
actually
forwarded me uh Dave Ramsey Show he is
we're we got a lot of the same goals in
common just we don't want to be you know
struggling living paycheck paycheck to
paycheck and we would like to be a
little more educated so
um that's kind of where I'm at so my
goal is to you know be successful and
not be struggling in life cool that's a
great goal to have and a great why so
I'll tell you my stance on this and we
hear this a lot I pay off my card in
full every month and here's the line
I've never paid a sent in interest we
always here I've never paid a dime in
interest and the truth is even if you
pay it off perfectly
every single study we've ever seen shows
that you spend more when you use a
credit card
which would by the way negate the two
percent you might be making off the card
and by the way if there's a single
misstep you're now being charged 22
percent
interest
every single time you carry that balance
and the studies show one uh 48 of people
pay off their card every month which
means 52 don't
and that's if they were telling the
truth we don't know if 48 were actually
telling the truth there but MIT has done
a study on this then they found with
fmri technology they examine the brain
during the point of purchase and they
found that the use of credit cards
activates the reward networks of the
brain which acts like a gas pedal
causing you to spend more
and so you ask what's the difference
between that and a debit card right
that's probably the next question that's
logical yeah well the difference is when
it's your money your body knows that
it's coming out of your bank account
instantly when it's their money that
you're borrowing your body tells you
that's kind of Monopoly money well
that's a problem for future Adrian we'll
deal with that later and so
psychologically it's different the other
difference is you physically can't spend
money you don't have and with a credit
card you can easily do that and you're
kind of just hoping you can cover the
bill at the end of the month
so that's just one side of the coin and
I'll tell you because I was that guy
Adrian I had in 2013 I had a Discover
card for the five percent rotating cash
back and guess where it rotates
restaurants entertainment travel
things that we would all agree are kind
of luxury spending
and so all of a sudden we're chasing
five percent on a meal that costs us six
times what it would what it would have
cost us if we just made that same meal
at home and so I actually interviewed a
Capital One credit cards uh manager who
used to work there on my podcast a fine
print you can go check that episode out
called the uh the true cost of credit
card Awards and she told me Point Blank
that these companies do thousands and
thousands of experiments on the
consumers every single year to get them
to spend more to get them to be that rat
in the Maze trying to get to the cheese
to think that they won
so this idea that uh consumers think I
can beat the system yes they're out
there and they're all over Tick Tock and
it gets lots of use because who doesn't
want to do that yeah everybody wants to
win the game everybody wants to win and
the truth is the credit card companies
love that you think that they love that
you're bragging about your rewards to
all of your friends going guys I figured
out the hack yeah man I'm really taken
Capital One of the cleaners with this
hack
now bro they love that you think you're
winning have you seen their offices all
around the country yeah they sponsor
stadiums giant where's Adrian Stadium
that's what I want to see I like that
and so I've just found Ken that as soon
as I cut up the cards I was able to
build wealth on my terms spending money
I actually had and I weirdly didn't miss
the rewards and Miles I just went I want
to book a flight is that on the budget
oh okay cool
great no it's not simple it is no
confusing point system going well I have
30 000 points but that amounts to seven
dollars and gift cards or why play that
game yeah it's mentally taxing it's
exhausting I mean Ken's just falling
asleep just thinking about having to
play this game yeah it's exhausting just
book a flight you know so that's my
stance Adrian uh I'd love it I'd find
better tick-tockers like Ken Coleman and
George Campbell the great start an
absolute great start on there we're
trying to dispel all this nonsense there
you go Addison is up next in Kansas City
Addison how can we help
uh yeah hi guys thanks for having me on
sure what's up
um so I work as an Amazon associate make
about 18 per hour about 37k income I
currently have five thousand dollars in
student loans but I'm also looking to
purchase a new card as my car has been
through the bringer that I currently
have
so
um I've been looking at about a 7.5 K
car just about an A to B and I also want
to get those student loans paid off as
soon as possible I currently have 10K in
the bank in order to pay completely cash
for the car have no payments anything
like that that
um and I was kind of wondering what to
do with that uh student loan area
because I also have a there's a
dependent account under my mom
that has about five grand minimum in it
and I've been wanting to get in contact
with her so that I can pull that over
under my bank account and use that to
sort of not have to worry about future
building interest
um on that uh student loans
so how does that account what the best
way is to tackle so you move that 5000
over how does that affect your student
loan
just so I can pay them off as soon as
possible and get them out of the way and
be sort of debt free okay and your car
right now is it needing repairs or is it
actually on the fritz where is that at
like could it survive for another five
months it's in need of repairs it's got
210 000 miles on it and I mean I feel
like it would be just a better
investment to go for a used car that is
of better well what would the repairs
cost me
um I have not gotten a quote on that but
um it's got to be thousands of dollars I
mean it the exterior is damaged and then
there's obviously stuff wrong with the
interior transmission wise
and
um there yeah there's there's it's got
quite a few problems with it okay well
I'm gonna do just a little more homework
actually go to the mechanic and see what
they say about it because if it's a
thousand bucks and it'll fix it up for
the next 12 months even six months as
you continue saving up I'd rather see
you knock out these student loans and
then upgrade uh but if the car is really
like you say it is and it's going kaput
it's okay to use that money and get a
real reasonable car and not set yourself
back on that student loan payoff yeah
yeah I agree good advice that's what we
do here can we try we try our best
fantastic heavy lifting this this
segment George way to go I'm here for
you to take it on your shoulders hey
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five to jump in on the
conversation our scripture of the day
comes from James 1 4 and let endurance
have its perfect result so that you may
be perfect and complete lacking in
nothing our quote of the day ah it's one
of my favorites I don't you love Steve
Martin don't you oh big fan thankfully
persistence is a great substitute for
talent says one of the most talented
dudes on the planet I mean I thought he
was special and then like after all
these years in comedy when he's you know
the man's still as sharp as he was 30
years ago I want a Grammy for Bluegrass
yeah incredibly talented Bluegrass
musician banjo player uh you know he
once tweeted at me well it wasn't in a
good way I said something snarky and me
it was back in 2009 or 2010. you snarked
at Steve Martin and I snarked and I
tagged him like a big troll and he
snapped back what did he did again and
he called me a sad idiot child and I'll
never forget it I scribe might as well
frame it in my house um called you a sad
idiot child do you still have that tweet
um I do have it I'll show you the
screenshot once we're off air maybe
we'll put it on air later actually
George and I are together Friday I'd
like that to make it to the show uh
because I that is now my new nickname
for you the sad idiot child said it is
because I think I called him like a
crazy old grandpa and so he was it was
the perfect snap back from Steve Martin
I gotta tell you the fact that you got a
return of serve is impressive there's
only two ways to do it either be real
nice to a celebrity or be a jerk and
eventually they'll say yeah they're
sensitive I can get it let's go to
Savannah who joins us right here in the
Nashville area Savannah how can we help
hi thank you for taking my calls my name
Savannah I'm calling because I recently
was accepted into the Vanderbilt MBA
program
um I ended up deferring it for a year
because for financial reasons because
it's about 60k a year two year program
holy smokes and I currently don't have
any former student debt but my husband
has a little bit and I know that I could
probably double my salary doing this
program but I'm just deciding if it's
worth it to take out such a significant
amount of debt
um for the MBA
what do you plan to do after the MBA
so right now I'm working in my
in like which would yes supposedly
double my salary but honestly I'm not
even sure if that's exactly what I want
to do I'm kind of just chasing the
salary aspect of it
I just feel like it's a wet finger in
the air like I think it'll double my
salary or what if it doesn't and you're
120 000 in debt and I've got and I've
actually yeah I know and I'm going to
tell you the Savannah and I'm very
passionate about this you can take this
or leave it you called here the free
here's the free advice that MBA is not
going to double your salary you will
right
right you will right and if you want to
do Consulting with data analytics is
that what I'm to understand
exactly yeah so getting into data
analytics and by the way this is this is
for the moment we're putting to the side
the fact that you don't even know if you
want to do data analytics and I would
venture to say you don't and you're just
chasing a salary you know what I
actually admire you for saying that I do
because I think that's a tremendous
amount of self-awareness to save you
some heartache now this is my particular
area of work as I focus on work and
meaningful work and living a life where
you're winning at work and that helps
you win in other areas of your life okay
so I'm really passionate about this I
would not touch this MBA with a 10-foot
pole until it was absolutely clear
that it was required in other words it
was the only way to get where you want
to go
and the second option is is it the best
way to get where you want to go so for
instance and I'm making this up if you
had a company that said hey Savannah
we'd like to hire you but we require an
MBA for your track
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah and
so it wouldn't be the only way to do
what you want to do but in that that
case it would be the best way because
you've identified an employer you want
to work for then I'd go okay this is a
this is a calculated risk I'd still cash
flow it I wouldn't take out the loan
it's not going to be worth it we've got
a great documentary on on it's
everywhere you can get documentaries
it's called borrowed future and if you
would just watch some of the stories
from people that make really big money
that are that were absolutely miserable
because of the pressure
from those loans I just don't want that
for you and I'll be honest with you you
could eventually if you need an MBA you
might be able to get a company to pay
for it or reimburse you uh if it's
absolutely needed I'm going to tell you
to win in data analytics or in most
business Fields the MBA doesn't get you
anything you get it and you win are
there good things that you learn in an
MBA program sure but at the end of the
day
um you don't need it and so don't take
out the loan that's a two-year program
yeah it's a two-year program what would
be the interest on that loan
I don't even know I didn't even look
into it because I immediately was so
scared
it off a year 120
000. like a huge amount of money it is
something here's the way I see it like I
needed a year if like Ken said it is
required no job description says MBA
from Vanderbilt required it just says
MBA required so if we're just here to
check the box then I would get the most
affordable MBA possible that you can do
online in your spare time while working
that would be the path great and when it
comes to Consulting a company that hires
you to do Consulting it's probably going
to be more proximity principle where
they said hey you got to get in touch
with Savannah she's the best in data
analytics they don't go hey we got to
Google MBA data analytics and we find
Savannah I don't think companies care
they want someone who knows what they're
doing in the data analytics world and
I'm not convinced that an MBA makes you
that much better at data analytics as
far as experience goes
what do you want to do I think you have
an idea
but you've been clouded by I got to make
this amount of money by this amount of
time in my life which I understand that
but I think you have a hunch I know
what's and if I'm wrong tell me but do
you have a hunch about which which way
you'd like to go professionally
yeah actually I really want to work with
my parents they own a business in
Virginia but I have to move back there
in order to do that and so that's just a
whole different story so I'm kind of
like if I'm living here maybe I need to
create my own path and I think I was
just starting to think all right what's
the path that's going to make me the
most but I think what I'd ultimately be
passionate about is working in the
family business what is that what's the
business
they own a travel company they take
students on trips all around the world
and they've been doing it together since
I was six years old okay so we don't we
only have about two minutes so we won't
unpack the whole story but what's the
big give me the bumper sticker reason
why going back to Virginia makes your
stomach turn at least it sounded like it
um I want to support my husband in
pursuing his career Here and Now
and none that and we're kind of just
riding the wave and seeing where that
goes and when you say support how much
money are you making right now
I'm making together we're making 200 I'm
contributing 85 to that 85. okay here's
you know the question I would have is
can you do similar work to what your mom
and dad's business does and and bring in
a decent amount of money to support him
in this season
because that's the work you love it's
not so much just the family it's you
like the travel component I just wonder
if if you don't go that direction and
make as much as you can and you and the
hubs change your budget if you can only
make 65. sounds like you guys are making
good money
yeah is there room to do that remotely
could you do it from Nashville at all
have you talked to your parents about
what that would look like
I could do it's exactly what you guys
are saying I could do certain lower
paying roles as our company from
Nashville
um I just wouldn't be able to be like a
manager higher up at their company from
here but I can help them with all kinds
of things remotely it feels like that's
your path do you see yourself eventually
taking over
I would love to where's the hubs at they
don't sell the business where's the hubs
at on all this
so he would be interested in working
there too but there just hasn't been a
good opportunity to come up for the both
of us there so I think honestly maybe we
need to sit down with my parents and
make a plan I think it's in the picture
and all of that why don't we you know
what why don't we dream a little before
we start deciding what we're gonna do
when we're gonna do it I think we gotta
have a big picture plan I landed way
more excited about this travel plan than
the 120 Grand MD 100 so I think we've
decided Savannah you decided George and
I just jumped on board with you we're
Team Savannah no NBA let's let's have a
talk with the hubs and the parents and
figure out a long-term plan George good
how hour thank you my friend you're the
best thanks Austin and the crew behind
the glass keeping us on the air and you
America for listening this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramseysolutions.com and
click get started
[Music]